benvenuti solite scritto nell italia e
oggi nuova challenge refertate una
vendetta lo sly consolle sono temi
questo in tantissimi fan che vi piaciuto
tantissimo ha deciso di fare una
vendetta questa volta ci sono anche cose
più cattivo e qua perché non ha seguito
all'episodio precedente precisamente noi
faremo lo slime con ingredienti che ci
disse alla ruota
poi ogni volta che capita buttalo
dovremmo buttare tutti gli strumenti che
abbiamo dentro vecchie dell'altrettanto
la crisi potrebbe succedere che una
persona rimane con pochissimo o niente
del secchio e l'altra rimane questi
secchio di voi mi sarà stilato per molto
incanto fine del video come sempre
dovrete votare se vinco io team rosso
zii o con air ottima azzurro in base
alla bellezza e il suo unitario
questo coraggio lasciate un bel live che
se volete altre zone insulari con la
ruota così gli stessi purchè sociale
spazio nei commenti prendete il boccone
quanto capita che gli piaceva alla
bianca perché poi per i pasti ammette
allora ok arrugginita e tutti gli altri
30 e speriamo che capiti a un mezzo
contenuta per cambi e non è stata posta
a mano sposta schiava da vivere
perché quando lo potrei nel mio cioè non
faccio chiudere gli occhi al contrario
allora originale chiudere gli occhi a 7
nel frattempo piazza devi girare la mano
e pescare dove so c'è un artistico
quello che poi completare bene dove
rimesso il bardolino dal decimo piano
sentire chi è mamma si chiama il
permesso sacco e zia gigantesco stato di
non doverlo affrontare ha detto fatto
a distanza di tre mesi che dai drogati o
lo diamo via parola che siamo fortunati
pensavo addio alla società una volta ma
è un tiro mai bello non come l'ultima
volta dopo azione che bello sarei
l'artico è ancora colore papa c'è un
bloccata un bebè vedrai che vi capita
con il bellissimo
[Musica]
tuttavia famiglia tuttavia dai live per
questo quando metti metti di ufficio ma
che bella 1 online quel gigante sarebbe
l'ansaldo fatto legge rota un conto
chirac e berti con tantissima colla e
può essere
[Musica]
mi ha buttato ok un acuto barbuta mi
lascia un po di residuo azzurro forse
quando aggiungerai il giallo firenze
capitale è ritornato da me perché blu e
quindi sa che questa coltura mai cantar
vittoria troppo presto
grazie ad esso non è giusta ma la dinamo
torna sul futuro al sicuro che vi
trovate
vedremo cioè tre volte cantato il quale
proprio il testo distribuito un po e un
po celeste molto chiaro
[Musica]
dolorante a occhi chiusi
ok abbiamo tanti coloranti qua almeno
quelli e quelli grandi occhi dai
scegliere volo a ok alle regioni ha
detto vale a scamparla il bene per lo
stato il governo delle nevi presto
questo qui turchese acque dopo è
cambiata la zia e delta arancione il
celeste dimetterà che già vediamo che il
colore diventa doveroso bene dai piano
[Musica]
tanto il genietto 21 si butta niente
vediamo un po se non lo faccio vorrei
che diventa proprio la radio come
diritto di tutti l'altro ieri che non mi
è costato 1 trovato in me però perché
sono un po li lascia un pochettino di
blu lido il toc toc aver speriamo bene
[Musica]
ferro festeggiate che fortuna il dubbio
non asia tifosi quindi lo chiudi gli
occhi aspetta dove cadrà ma non renderli
aspetta dai
[Musica]
per volto bello viola profitto diventa
celeste che vediamo un po di che colore
diventa fan e celeste prima devo
ammettere il viola dai oppure ha visto
che ci sono tutti questi colori viola
diventa un grazie ma con ora perché
eletto un turchese pomeriggio dopo lilla
con forlì lo pubblicò the proprio un
azzurro grigio ma diventerà via e grigio
blu detto carmelo briguglio qualche
ingrediente buono di noi
grant che voglia ad alta voce che mi
capita a e b
[Musica]
con l'ultima di campionato ma se capita
mette contro i nitrati che fortuna così
adesso mi diventa più chiaro
diamo una donna in via da tendere
pupazzi mitilo dai terribili e propri
giusta questa gialla da papà che fortuna
non è stato più chiaro un bellissimo
celeste bellissimo koikili salviola a
chi tocca a te a me
[Musica]
clip dal rosso di capitan maniera minore
è possibile grazie a tutti dai schiuma
scorreggione ma sempre quando davanti un
po questi rumori strani bello famoso
rischiamo diventa meta
no è possibile diventare un celeste
ancora più chiaro che non sarà più per
grigio brutto delle del dopo averlo
vecchio non sarà più col grigio brutto
ma sarà un celeste chiaro rimando è
stupenda un celeste molto delicato
questo come il mio team è bello adesso
su giungo dei kit gara il regista il
ritorno di capitano io sono sempre senza
niente con qualche rimasuglio chi
vincerà chi vince
[Musica]
tuttavia mi perseguita che facciano
niente la tutto
ci sia un coach barbuto bellezza novità
le forse un altro questa saga
spiegatemelo la spiga più totale
essendo la vuota io c'è la volontà che a
tratti male io non lo faccio girare per
te l'ha provata ha provato qui gira come
roger li accontentano nella finale ruota
la nuova e quindi lei è contenta quando
dico perché magari ti capita buttano e
va tutto a me kakà è il tocco comando
della no fly line o meno male
[Musica]
ma non è tutto perché no mi vedevi
commenti e dissociazione su montella
vero se tu guardi registra qui su scegli
tu nel centro america laziale dove
scelta tra aziende e beni allora ripeto
tutti visto che stai in mezzo la ruota
nell'asse muto e decidere quindi gli
studi all'asta in mezzo mettiamo già
iniziati allora io cercando di parare
non è vero perché secondo me secondo me
secondo me scrivendo quindi commenti era
un fiato che youtube era scegli tu
come al solito anita bar
[Musica]
sono tutti veramente belli è
praticamente devo ammettere la neve
finta senza qua quindi voglio proprio
vedere come diventa ecco qua ma trova
mischia nato che succeda qualcosa è la
miss che speriamo che si attivino cosa
vi è un po strana così il tempo sono poi
qui celeste di fondo sembra quasi ne
vedeva è brutta ma nemmeno bella
vediamo vediamo un po perché altri
rilievi come diventa magari diventa più
bella ma stiamo scherzando se devi
andare con questa cosa qui a questo
latte scaduto contro il mio bellissimo
sliven celeste che poi potrebbe capitare
a me io caro che a te o meglio è
[Musica]
nei camini debuttante
come il tutto con schiuma soluzione team
ai tantissimo condividiamo via tuttavia
anche bello tra l'altro è diventato
multicolor fatto io certo che bello a
tanti sfumato edizione est è bellissimo
perché ho fatto io mi diventerà con
l'opzione neve finta che non esista una
schifezza
raccogliamo visto quello che avevamo ad
altri usi
quindi non rovinare il medico vi aspetta
aspetta
io so perché ma che si è mai quello no
no
è il turchese che praticamente e tv il
bello doveva arrivare alla delibera non
è un altro precedesse chiaro poi bianco
e celeste sembra celo celo celo d'estate
per gallarate canto ballo e di chi è
sembrato sembrava di sicuro non turchet
e quello che poi dopo si delinea pensavi
e al mercato di allora ricandidata tra
forse riesco a di lui erano un po che
fate vista già sparendo perché la
colletta solo scendendo più in basso che
ci dai quasi sparito e più celestino ho
fatte io invece devo solo vedere di
fondi del nostro live beh qualcosa
allora ultimo turno per vitale e poi
l'ultimo turno per me quelli questi sarà
mite un ride city
potremmo perdere tutto o vincere tutto
intanto d'ottobre miracolo zio piano
perché tuo ultimo torno
tu sei grande
[Musica]
sono state tenute come cosa dovevo fare
che fortuna è questa e una scelta
difficile perché potresti o abbellirlo
con glitter o colorante oppure
aggiungere la colla però poi rimarrebbe
un colore molto chiaro con i capelli
sicuro ma rimane piccolissimo ma sai
perché mi confido nel buttano tuo che io
adesso l'obelisco e poi posso sperare
che la spiga che chiamava taxes se
succede così veramente è la fine
completa si scandalizzano quali penso di
aver vestito la prendo questi dall alto
176 ma non darti un consiglio o meno
peggio per te bianca certo desiderano si
vedono poco a poco
allora però questi qua quelli cari è
allora non ho deciso questi gli olo
bellissimo si sono uniti non torno
permessi
potrei perdere giunto dai 13 temi bene
per l'ultimo tratto bene che io ti
faccio girare veloce questa volta
proprio parenti non è vero abbiamo seri
portafortuna vediamo ma questo mi sono
salvato stava andando sul punto di vista
anche la tratta
ne saranno muscolo te l'avevo detto che
sta riducendo le sorprese belle altresì
le righe 13 ma potremo uscire qualcosa
di rosso dentro
buongiorno vita di gaza all'inizio o
alla fine sono stata fortunata maniero
cosa tutto il mio cuore
vediamo come tanti vediamo un po
tantissimi degree e dicevi che non si
vedevano fatto che bello che è diventato
libertà fa con la sola perché sei gelosa
non brillano invece ci porterà il colle
traspare un fatto uno slime un minuscolo
ma guarda che bello
bene io tolgo online contro gigatribe
cioè la colla raccolta dalle pareti
delle risposte
che bello che bello creativa ed emotiva
già attivo praticamente talmente poco
che succhiano un attimo dovrei faticare
invece il braccio per attivare il mio
gigante il mio poi più bello guardero il
mio è più belle e nino raccogliamo tutto
tutto tutto tutto con raccogliere le
pareti verses precarietà e quindi ora
non è blu con brillantini viola che era
andiamo ad attivare il mio mega james
tobin bell dentro 23 21
ecco qua news rai ma gigantesco guardate
è enorme hawking fantastico il colore è
un celestino chiaro c'è questo simoni
cosa che tu pensi stima sembra una
nuvoletta
[Musica]
megafoni gigante che non le date a
questo time davvero fantastico metterei
giocarsi troppo rilassate perché no
[Musica]
quelli che alla fine sito cari non so
come i bit air si vedono morire perché
tu devi ascoltare quando dicono una cosa
e celeste con i glitter viola da un
polipo chi viola stellato il cielo
azzurro con le stelle viola viviamo ci
muoviamo gli affianca non ci si aspetta
la piazza io in realtà malata troppo per
farlo sempre più grande è questo il mio
slime jazz live se lo mangia il tuo sito
c'è chi fugge il piccolino e prezioso
bello questo l'ho fatto io e non è mio
ma allora un fortunale flachi bis se
vinco io
grosso se vincevi cade team blu e ora
sono state per berlino supplicare
problemi dei nostri altri video clicca
su quella che preferite e vogliono
inviare ciao